adam sosnick here on behalf of
valuetainment we are here in deep
ellum downtown dallas texas people are
saying
that this is the most important
presidential election of our lifetime
people are saying that the polls are too
close to call
so we're gonna find out what the people
are saying about the presidential
election
so there's an election in a few days are
you planning on voting
who do you uh who do you vote for not
who is currently
president you're not you're not voting
for trump no are you guys voting
we're already here we already have would
you tell us who you're voting for
um trump biden trump i already voted and
i voted for biden
joe you voted for joe biden joe
jorgensen
joe jorgensen amen so you flipped it on
me i thought you were going joe biden i
did now here's my question for you
why did you waste your vote dramaall
name
would you mind sharing who you voted for
biden trump uh
biden biden i'm voting for biden uh
biden you're voting for biden i am also
voting for joe biden so we got two joe
bidens nobody
you're not voting i am actually not
voting this year
are you guys voting no no no no no
we got three non-voters give us the main
reason that
you are voting for biden and the main
reason that you voted main reason main
policy issue
go ahead policy issue i guess uh his
plan on climate change
i disagree with trump's policies almost
across the board
i think he has a better policy and he
knows what
he is planning to do in next like four
years instead of saying just let's make
america great
again i mean just because i want to get
trump out not because
of any other reason really straight up
how about you i totally agree yep
okay i like some things about biden i
think he has the ability to lead us into
a better
situation in the united states than
we're currently in i think right now
it's uh like all the black lives matter
movement and like equal rights
uh probably social justice well his
experience in the white house clearly i
think he's genuine
he's personable and actually cares about
people his immigration policies are more
in line with what i'm
comfortable with because i love lgbtq
community i want to support them and i
believe like
human rights are important make america
great again
less taxes biden wants to cut those tax
breaks he wants to put taxes back
on us i don't think biden is
mentally fit at this point in time
because he says what he means and he
does what he says
would you say one nice thing about trump
no nothing zero i don't think there is
any good thing there's nothing you could
say
more people think that trump is more
outspoken he cares for his his kids i
guess
trump is consistent in being
trump he's consistently trump
uh melania's pretty melania's pretty i
would agree with that
i would say the nicest thing i could say
about trump
is that i appreciate the change that he
made that allows people the right to try
i don't think i have one um the economy
is doing well
okay how about you um i do agree
with some of the criminal justice reform
policies that he has
supported i think he tries hard but his
motives are just
not what a normal american would
think is uh moral
uh i think he has great stage presence
like he is definitely a showman you know
as a business owner
i think you know he did pretty good on
you know like tax cuts so
i like trump because i think he is
realistic about certain
things in the economy i like the way
he's uh
i think i like his policies regarding
trade in terms of china
i like that he says the way he feels
that's what's on his sleeve
seems sincere he's unified the
democratic party
say one nice thing about joe biden uh i
think
i think joe biden is trying to take
things in a different direction
so i'm not completely against that
biting let me see
i think you have a lot of support um i
think joe has done his time
and i think he tried to help in 47 years
probably he tried
um and i i wish him all in his
retirement
one nice thing uh he's worked for the
united states of america for a long time
one nice thing about joe biden he's a
sensible man
joe biden has been you know a loyal
american for
what 79 years and and uh
i mean he's presidential um he's figured
out how to do this for a very long time
which has secured his personal
fortune as far as biden i feel like he's
just
you get that more down to earth
realistic
feel from him he's a nice guy he seems
to be a straight shooter too
i just want uniformity and stability
and just low stress
one nice thing about trump one nice
thing about biden they can kiss ma
they can both kiss her ass that's the
nice thing good for you guys
give us a final takeaway you're from
your perspective of the election
personally i think everyone should vote
and i think that no matter who wins
we should all get along personally me i
think it's part of the same head either
way for me you know
i don't think either of the candidates
are the right fit for america
but suits who is less bad it's the
election is going to be a little scary
i'm really scared about what's going to
happen on tuesday everything about him
just needs to be
gone final thoughts i mean if biden's
president it can only get better
if if trump becomes president i'm moving
to colombia
if i could do one thing it'd be to flip
the narrative
uh change the fact that voting third
party
um is not actually a waste of a vote um
voting for who you align with
best is exactly what americans should do
that's what our freedom allows us to do
yeah i mean i
feel like i'm living in a science
fiction novel
it's kind of unreal but i guess if this
is
you know if people are gonna be watching
this i would say for anybody that's like
undecided whether or not to vote i just
hope people
go out and vote whatever way you know
whichever way you want to vote is fine
but
i hope that people have found motivation
that they want to you know be a part of
this democratic process and exercise
that right so that
whatever happens you can say you at
least cast your vote in
you know made your choice so as you can
see i hit the streets of downtown dallas
right before the election and i
interviewed all
sorts of people and here's what i
uncovered i was actually
expecting being that i'm in texas to get
more people voting
for trump but actually what i uncovered
was the majority of people were voting
for biden so that shocked me my
breakdown was as follows
70 of people were voting for biden
20 of people were voting for trump and
10 just straight up weren't voting at
all
so to me that was the most disappointing
not voting
so now that you're seeing this right
after the election i hope you voted and
i hope
you participated in american democracy
now if you like this episode you should
check out this episode right here
my breakdown of trump versus biden's
policies
and if you have not subscribed to
valuetainment economics please do so
below and as always
save that money all we talk is